today on stick to football a tease mock
draft Monday baby Connor Rogers and I
going through all 32 pics of the first
round we're not crazy enough yet to do
two rounds on a podcast gotcha buddy we
got a lot of news to go through college
football NFL a lot has been happening
we got coaching changes we got some
other coaches that probably need changed
but also in about five days we have the
tailgate of the century Alabama versus
LSU 8:00 a.m. on the quad it's gonna be
free drinks free food we're gonna have
cornhole we're gonna have hugs koozies
and stickers to give away special guests
guests coming by and of course
me you and Mela will be there of course
man it's gonna be awesome I can't wait I
feel like the turnout is gonna be pretty
overwhelming for this one and once again
our guests line up but I don't want to
get too crazy and give it away yet but
we have a very solid you sweetie that
you can all right there then I mean
we're gonna have Adam Kramer from
Bleacher Report we're gonna have Landon
Collins stopping by the tailgate which
was the big surprise guests that I've
been hiding for weeks I mean we're gonna
have Jacob Hester LSU Legend and of
course our buddy Jim naggy from the
Senior Bowl it's gonna be coming as well
that's four very different very awesome
guess for this stick to football
tailgate yeah it's gonna be a good time
we kept the Landon Collins thing quiet
because you know you never know in this
business when like just people's
schedules can fall through and you're
like we won't let's get to game week and
then we'll start talking about it but
I'm very excited because we do have I
think four amazing guests for my money
Adam Kramer is the best college football
writer in America jacob hester is a
legend a gym naggy you guys know how
fond we are of him and then we got
landed Colin's reppin Alabama and one of
the best safeties in the NFL so it's
gonna be a great time 8:00 a.m. on the
quad if you can make it come out because
it is going to be legendary is it such a
good time also our old internal walkers
gonna be there our buddy our original
intern Adam Heisler is gonna be there
it's gonna be like a little bit of a
stick to football reunion so it's gonna
be a good time for all of us for sure
let's jump right into the news though
not a good time for Willie tagger or
maybe it is because making a lot of
money the buyout for Willie Taggert is
like 18 million dollars
Florida State actually raised twenty
million dollars in private donations to
fire their head coach how bad are you at
your job when people are donating 20
million dollars this is okay Katrina
it's a football coach JJ Watt raised a
third of this when a city was decimated
by a hurricane
Willie Taggart so bad at his job Florida
State gives 20 million in donations in
24 hours it's amazing that that's insane
I mean Jets fans are raising money to
fire Adam GaSe right now there's a
GoFundMe for that but it has not reached
20 million dollars but listen I'm sure
Willie's obviously upset about this this
job meant a lot to him it's a shame it
didn't work out but when it comes down
to it it never really felt like this was
the move to get Florida State back to
the glory days it just never had that
kind of electrifying sense around it
Florida State has barely been treading
water and that's not the kind of program
they are they're the kind of program
that should be in the college football
playoff talk every single season not the
will they make a bowl game talk that's
how bad things have gotten
and when you're the head coach it's
gonna fall back on you now I think the
biggest question a lot of people are
wondering Matt is what kind of pull does
this job have anymore and where can they
go from here yeah because I thought
Willie Taggart was a bad hire when they
made it it felt like oh this is not
Florida State this is a legacy higher
right so may I know the names that have
been out there are guys like Mark Stoops
who's at Kentucky you've got I've seen
PJ flex name mention which I actually
really like PJ fleck a lot and Minnesota
they they're having a fantastic year
he's a great head coach but then you
know like you you kind of get into those
hires like Mike Norvell at Memphis like
no disrespect to Mike Norvell Memphis
has done a very good job this year but
our Mike Norvell and Mark Stoops like is
that where Florida State's at where
you're not saying let's go get a guy
like Todd Monken in the NFL who the
Browns are just completely misusing his
brothers to head coach at army I think
he'd be a great college football head
coach or why are you trying to look at
you know at a PJ Fleck look at the
mid-majors of teams who are doing really
really good and you see awesome team
building I mean they're so many options
here I think Matt
is destined for the NFL but if you're
not Florida State
yeah I mean but that's like that's who
Florida State used to go get you used to
look at your coaches in college and say
hey that's our guy like we can go we can
get Matt rule Florida State is just
they've fallen behind so far and it's
not like Miami's great but in Florida we
saw lose to Georgia that was a tough
game for them but there I think I mean
they're the best team in Florida Florida
State right now is the third best team
in their own state and for the first
time in my life of watching college
football that's the case I mean it's
just it's embarrassing and hopefully
they get it turned around
I know fans are saying like they don't
have the facilities to compete neither
does Miami okay let's be honest none of
those schools in Florida are just you
know dripping with facilities like you
see in Texas and Ohio State and Oklahoma
so I don't really buy that excuse I
think they just got it wrong going from
Jimbo Fisher to willie Taggart Matt I
don't even know if they're better than
UCF right now they might be history yeah
yeah I know you do things are bad and
the good news is like we always say when
things are really bad hopefully they can
only get better from here I do find it
fascinating because when these jobs open
up of course the biggest name candidates
get listed in possibility my thoughts on
Matt rule are this Matt rule wants the
NFL Matt rule really wanted the NFL last
year but wanted things his way in a way
hey this is how I think I could succeed
and the Jets weren't willing to handle
hand him that yet but that was very
close to happening and there's gonna be
a lot of jobs opening up where Matt rule
was gonna get the call whether that's
the Jets again whether that's the New
York Giants it goes on and on and on and
if those jobs aren't for him I think
he's pretty happy at Baylor right now
considering they're undefeated in the
program that he's rebuilt there so it's
gonna be an interesting different list
for FSU I stand with you that I think PJ
Flex should be the guy because in a way
is it bold and risky yes but I think the
last two teams that hired PJ flex said
that thought that and now they're
reaping the benefits from that and one
other name off they're out there I love
this guy at appstate and now he's at
Louisville they're playing really well
now Scott Satterfield and our play is an
up-and-coming head coach candidate I
know that would be a little under the
radar and we were just saying like your
Florida State you should be able to get
the best of the best
I really think centerfield is destined
for a power 5j a big power 5 job and I
know that like right now Louisville to
Florida State you might think that's a
lateral move but the athletes that you
can get a Florida State are it like it's
almost incomparable the type of athlete
that you can get there if you're willing
to dig in and do the work so I would
keep it on Scott standard here and
there's a wild one for you before we
close it out if Notre Dame fires Brian
Kelly could you see them going that
route oh yeah absolutely I thought you
were gonna say Mike Leach cuz that was
that was myelin that is wild right like
just go crazy I mean at this point if
you're Florida State yes roll the dice
roll the dice so yeah we'll be talking
about this one you know right up until
it happens but moving over to the NFL I
feel like we say this every year but I
truly mean it right now this is the best
number one pick race I can remember in
quite some time where I truly do not
know who is going to get this pick right
now we're gonna do a mock drafted a full
first-round as matt said earlier in the
show and right now the top eight shake
out like this the bengals redskins
jets dolphins falcons Giants Browns and
bucks that's the top eight order now
those teams have zero to two wins which
means a lot of [ __ ] can change right
let's just get a State of the Union here
from you Matt of how this is all shaking
out well Cincinnati and I've said this
for months now we didn't expect him to
tank but they're ona and they're playing
fourth round pick
Ryan Finley a quarterback so they are
effectively done and someone asked me I
I wish I could remember if it was on the
podcast or on radio last week someone
was like who do you think would win if
Miami and Cincinnati played see I think
Miami would win like they're just that
linebacker core from Miami is [ __ ]
amazing they are so much fun to watch I
think Cincinnati's the worst team in
football but like you said crazy things
could happen Washington's gone to Dwayne
Haskins who it looks like he was told
not to throw the ball down the field
yesterday I mean down they look terrible
the Jets lost to the Dolphins so there's
that I mean you just sit right there
that's a point I need to know Atlanta is
reeling they've lost six in a row so it
is a wild race if I had to BET right now
I would say Cincinnati holds the first
pick in the draft
and you know most likely that means
that's where to attack of Milo's gonna
go what's interesting is for me right
now Miami is the fourth pick and you
look at Miami schedule the rest of the
way they might win a couple ballgames
couple more ballgames honestly so when
you look at Miami it's like damn they
could be a three win team and out of
that you know we're gonna get the top
quarterback and we'll run through that
in our mock draft that we're doing in
segments two and three but this is why
Miami traded to get all those extra
draft assets this is like when
Philadelphia traded up to get Carson
Wentz they knew in advance and they were
willing to make the trades to come up to
Tennessee to come up to Cleveland I
think we see Miami right now Miami would
pick for 17 and 25 well 17 to 25 by
themselves aren't getting you very far
but I wouldn't be surprised if we see
them package a four and 17 to try to get
up there not that washing to a draft
quarterback not that the Jets would you
have to quarterback but to make sure
that no one else gets up there to get a
jobber owe to get a Justin Herbert and
we've got a couple months left to see
how it goes but the Dolphins are taking
a quarterback and they're in a position
whether it's let's wait and see if one
of those guys Falls to four or if they
feel like someone's gonna jump them or
someone would take a quarterback ahead
of them they have the draft capital to
move up the board now yeah it's
fascinating the way it's broken down
because it's hard to imagine the Jets
and the Dolphins doing business so the
Dolphins will have to work with
Washington like you said you can't
discount Atlanta continuing to lose we
can't discount the dysfunctional Browns
continuing to lose they lost a Denver
yesterday I mean that's how bad things
are the Bucs want to get in this
quarterback race the Giants really need
to stay in this top eight because they
desperately need a franchise tackle and
there might only be one or two of them
if at all in this draft so the top picks
in this draft right now it's a super
tight race a lot of teams play each
other and it's gonna be really
interesting when we do make all the
picks in our mock draft moving on
actually sticking with two of the teams
that were in this conversation because
both of their head coaches might be
fired by the time the show comes out
Adam GaSe Freddie kitchens what more do
you need to see they were disastrous
hires for different reasons we already
knew Adam GaSe was coming out of Miami
but when you look at Freddie this was a
giant roll the dice they listen to their
quarterback and Baker it may feel
to make this higher the team's not
disciplines the offense is not running
even close to what it was last year the
Jets are a disaster from top to bottom
I just think Matt it would be a surprise
at this point if either of these guys
make it through the entire season I
think so
with the Jets specifically because I
know everyone wants to say like well Joe
Douglas and Adam GaSe are friends
doesn't I are friends and I think we've
been friends a little bit longer than
they have if you were like say I'm the
GM and you're the head coach Connor and
you're making me look bad every week no
matter how good a friends we are if
you're putting my job at risk I'm gonna
have to say hey buddy like this isn't
working it's business it's not personal
the jobs not being done we're gonna have
go different directions and I feel like
that's where we're going with this and
remember Joe Douglas didn't hire Adam
GaSe it doesn't matter if they hang out
on the weekends and they're best friends
I don't think it's that close but the
fact is I don't think Joe Douglas went
there because of Adam GaSe I think he
went there because of Sam Donald he went
there because of the money they're gonna
have in free agency and because of an
owner that was gonna be patient with a
rebuild hence the six-year contract so I
you know Adam GaSe is absolutely gone
here now Freddie kitchens I love John
Dorsey and people have listened to the
show for the two and a half years it's
been on know that I have a lot of
respect for John I think he's a great
evaluator where he's gotten in trouble
in the past is by sometimes trusting his
instincts over his head I think you
could look at some of the moves he made
in Kansas City to bring in some guys
with some off-field issues to just sign
guys to contracts that they weren't
worth they got into a little bit of
trouble there because of that now in
Cleveland you get hot and you let your
emotions take control of your decisions
and you let Baker Mayfield basically
pick your head coach and not only is
Baker regressing let's talk about a
quarterback who's been terrible this
year but that head coach is not working
and it also investing in Greg Robinson
and trusting Chris Hubbard as your book
inside offensive tackle and thinking
well let's just trade all of our assets
to get a wide receiver let's trade to
get another pass rusher instead of oh my
god our offensive line is absolutely
terrible
they've Mis played their hand a little
bit by thinking the Baker Mayfield is
good enough to overcome bad offensive
tackle play no one is good enough to
kind of overcome bad offensive tackle
play you saw that Sunday night what
Brady who's the best to ever do it so I
think the Browns they need to reset and
John Dorsey needs to get back to doing
what he's so good at that's team
building from the ground up so I think
Freddy kitchens is gone and I think for
both teams they can just say you know
what we messed up let's just admit own
in it now instead of waiting three years
and then we're really in over our heads
you got to just wipe the slate clean now
and if you're the Browns I think it's
gonna be Mike McCarthy if you're the
Jets I think you have to go to Matt rule
with a big
I'm sorry here's five million dollars a
year apology pick your own staff we
trust and believe you
that's exactly right Matt and I know a
lot of people will say well what can the
Browns do to get Lincoln Riley up there
back with Baker I just don't see that
one happening if I'm wrong I'll own it I
think Lincoln is very content Oklahoma
until a job like the Cowboys where you
can't say no opens up we'll see maybe
they can convince him it would really
shock me I do think they go with the
older experienced coach route that could
try to control the locker room I don't
know if I'd be a big believer in the
McCarthy hire but it's one that wouldn't
shock me at all with the GM that's there
I think when you look at the Jets
situation right now Christopher Johnson
made this hire he trusted Adam GaSe to
the point that he listened to him to
fire the front office but like you said
Joe Douglas got a six-year deal for a
reason I had heard rumblings before this
game that Adam GaSe was gonna be a
one-and-done coach when you go and lose
to the Dolphins it's the conversation
shifts from are you gonna be a
one-and-done coach too are you gonna
survive your first season with that team
and I'm with you all the way this
conversation starts and really ends was
going to get Matt rule he's somebody
that could bring credibility and respect
to this team this program and really
turned things around he's from New York
he's coached with the Giants who
probably will also be interested in him
this is a really good fit that always
should have happened in the first place
yeah it just these are the picked these
are the hires that should have happened
and we understand why they didn't but
it's time to make amends it's time to
fix these things and go get Matt ruling
for Cleveland I think Mike McCarthy is
what they they need someone who can
bring discipline and stability not even
with like Baker not even with Jermaine
Whitehead who you could Google what he
twe
I'm not gonna repeat any of it on this
podcast he goes off while still in
uniform in the locker room it's not
about like obj and Jarvis refusing to
comply with the you know NFL uniform
standards which are incredibly strict
there's just no discipline there they're
just letting the players run the team
that doesn't work they need someone who
can come in and straighten everything
out there let's move on to some injuries
because Jacoby Brissette and I will say
this Frank Reich should be coach of the
year let's just I'm gonna get that out
of the way head coach of the Year Tomlin
yeah geez Mike Tomlin they've been
they've been great as well and then
there's Kyle Shanahan who's doing okay -
but Jacoby Brissette gets hurt and the
Colts almost win this game if it wasn't
for Adam Vinatieri who's been I don't
want to turn into his legacy he's
probably greatest kicker of all time
he's been terrible
this shameful coach some games probably
should have retired over summer if it
wasn't for Adam Vinatieri we'd be talked
about Brian Hoyer winning a football
game against the Pittsburgh Steelers
whose defense looks amazing right now
makeup fitzpatrick has four picks since
being traded now from the Miami Dolphins
but Jacobi burr sets injury really can
open things up as far as the playoffs go
because that AFC South race between
Indianapolis and Houston is fascinating
I mean Indianapolis is 5 and 3 Houston
is 6 and 3 they're right there together
as far as this race goes if percept mist
is any amount of time you have to think
that Houston can really pull away and
run away with this thing right now
yeah I'm with you the question really
does pivot to Ken the Colts survived a
couple weeks without Jacoby perset now
they play the Dolphins that are coming
off their first win of the season where
they're probably pretty jacked up I
still think the Colts at home will beat
the Dolphins with it whether they have
Brian Hoyer or Jacobi percent at
quarterback now that could be a close
game
if Brian Hoyer starts but I think the
Colts will win that game in the trenches
but then you have Jacksonville and
Jacksonville did not look good in London
and Gardner Minshew we're gonna talk
about I mean did he lose his job I know
that's tough to say it's like you can't
even have one bad week and nick foles is
gonna be back soon that's gonna be an
interesting game but you really need
your Kobi back for when they play the
Texans because that's when the battle
for the division is officially on at the
end of this month so interesting
situation for the Colts they just keep
surviving I know this is a tough loss to
say you know to swallow but it's pretty
they were in this game to begin with
yeah and it's a sprained MCL that news
came out this morning so that he might
not miss any games at all but I think
the resolve of the Colts is really
fascinating
now our Guy Gardner Minshew did not play
well yesterday they go to London they I
mean no other way to put it he played
very badly against the Houston Texans
and there's been a lot of chatter over
the the 24 hours since that game and did
that maybe it's time to go back to Nick
Foles when he's healthy the gardner
minshew maybe the shine is off here's
what I would like to say about gardner
minshew
if he had been a first-round pick we
would say about yesterday's game bad
game he's been great look how well he's
a lead if he were a first-round pick
we'd be making every excuse Under the
Sun for this guy because he was a sixth
round pick we all want to sit here and
say not he's not good this is why he was
the sixth round pick if you look at the
picture if gardner minshew what he's
done on the field this year I still
believe that you roll with him because
of the contract because how inexpensive
he is for the next three years as a
quarterback option no that's not to say
that he will be the guy but it is way
too early after one bad game in London
by the way to say that oh Gardner
Minshew is not good this is what I hate
about NFL coverage and what I hope to
god you never get from us is this
wishy-washy week to week coverage of
football when the NFL has been viewed
for the prism of 17 weeks it would be
like coming on here this morning and
being like God the Patriots
suck did you see how bad they played
last night teams have bad games players
have bad games Gardner Minshew had a bad
game I don't think that says anything
about the viability of him as a starting
quarterback moving forward I'm with you
all the way I absolutely love that rant
because I think when you look at it it's
unfair and let's call it like we see it
this offense isn't anything special it's
not like he's sitting back there with
Sean McVeigh and all these weapons and
this great offensive line I know Leonard
Furness had a a really big comeback year
but what they have a wide receiver is
just okay I thought this offensive line
would be a lot better I don't think
they've been great by any means
necessary I think Gardner's actually
kind of mitigating the issues by his
ability his feel and movement in the
pocket so I'm with you I would roll with
this guy I know they
Nick Foles a lot of money maybe you go
back to Nick Foles this year but I would
get Gardner Minshew ready to start next
year and start building this team with a
cheap quarterback on the contract there
you probably can move Nick Foles with
how many teams need a quarterback and
won't be in position to draft one and
for Jacksonville it's an interesting
decision and it's it's gonna be
scrutinized one way or the other it
really is and like you said it's not
like he's I like their young receivers
but it's not like he's thrown to Jarvis
Landry and Odell Beckham and it's not
like his offensive line is very good at
all we're gonna talk about that when it
comes to mock draft Monday last thing we
have to touch on around the league the
Patriots finally lose there's one
unbeaten team in the NFL
the San Francisco 49ers the Patriots
lost and it really wasn't close to
something you and I were talking about
this morning the game never felt that
close even when the Patriots would get
within three or get within four they
played with a lot of mistakes it was
uncharacteristic there were fumbles
there were penalties and key moments the
Patriots looked rattled and I think a
ton of credit has to go to Lamar Jackson
it has to go to John Harbaugh the Ravens
offensive line played an exceptionally
well game yesterday just moving the
Patriots defense at will basically but
Lamar Jackson he doesn't always get it
done as a thrower he doesn't always get
it done as a runner but his instincts
his field vision and just the poise to
make a play to not be like oh my god
were playing the Patriots and it really
getting into his head I thought there
were moments where like the Ravens would
bog down and turn the ball over and it's
like okay is he gonna respond how is a
second-year quarterback going to handle
the adversity of knowing Tom Brady's on
the other sideline Bill Belichick's on
the other sideline and you just your
offense made a mistake or special teams
made a mistake it didn't bother him it
was like he was just you didn't you
would think he was playing Mitch or
Biscay on the other side but it never
entered Lamar Jackson's mind he didn't
seem like that he was having to face the
greatest head coach a greatest
quarterback of all time that's what I
always say about this Ravens team does
not fear New England and that starts
with two people in my opinion it starts
with John Harbaugh and it starts with a
22 year old quarterback that just is
unfazed
he's unfazed his ability to escape his
efficiency as a thrower
he's not giving away the football he's
been relatively accurate this year the
offense tailored around him has done
really it just a great job to Greg Roman
once again this coaching staff whether
it's the defensive coordinator whether
it's from the head coach the offensive
coordinator everyone's prepared and like
you said Matt the offensive line go back
and watch that film
they blew New England off the ball Mark
Ingram had plenty of momentum to get big
runs going time and time again and great
for Mark Ingram because that for agent
signing has been a big time hit he's
perfect for their offense and Earl
Thomas over there just brings a
different attitude to the back end of
the defense the front seven is getting
production out of guys that were
castoffs elsewhere late round picks the
Baltimore Ravens are one of those teams
I don't think anyone wants to run into
you in the postseason I'll say it right
now you have a quarterback that you
can't prepare for you have a defense
that has veteran presence and a lot of
hunger and a head coach that doesn't
really give a [ __ ] about any anyone else
that's what it comes down to he is the
quietest or the most low-key mf'er in
football right now it's it's crazy when
you watch them and the way they rally
around this team around this quarterback
at home it was extremely extremely
impressive it is mock draft Monday time
the Cincinnati Bengals are on the clock
and our guy Connor Rodgers is gonna play
GM for the odds I'm gonna play GM for
the evens
take it away Connor I mean let's not
overthink this one here I know there
will be some people that are wondering
if geo burrow can get in the
conversation maybe he does but right now
it's to a tongue about Aloha at number
one overall for the Bengals I know
they're gonna take a look at Ryan Finley
I don't think he's gonna change their
minds on anything with this pick that
would be a big shock to me with their
young coaching staff there and Zach
Taylor they're gonna get their
quarterback of the future into a cannot
argue with that I think we've been
saying it for months
whoever asked that number one pick if
they need a quarterback will be him the
only other pick that it could be would
be this gentleman who the Washington
Redskins picked number two overall chase
young selection here I know they drafted
Montes wet last year in the first round
I think as long as Dwayne Haskins
doesn't just completely fall apart they
would go with the pass rusher here chase
young one of the best defensive players
I've ever scouted this is a very very
easy pick for the Washington Redskins
it's very easy he's the best player in
this track
often I don't care that they have Montez
swag go get yourself another pass rusher
he'll be phenomenal for them I wish you
fell here to number three with the Jets
but the Jets aren't getting that lucky
this time but I'll happily take Jerry
Judy yet Samms Arnold the number one
wide receiver hopefully we get a
coaching staff in here that has some
idea of what they're doing and not
ruining the quarterback because Sam
Donald has regressed going from Jeremy
Bates to Adam GaSe yes the offensive
line needs to be rebuilt I don't see a
player at number three that you would
take over Judy in this spot they're
gonna be very proactive on the trade
market to fix this line they're gonna be
very proactive in free agency and guess
what Matt they're probably gonna have
more than one first-round pick yeah I
think there's a good chance for that
number for the Miami Dolphins the team
that has more than one first-round pick
and I like I like what you're getting
out I don't know people cuz they can't
if you're watching on YouTube you get
what Connors talking about because the
facial expressions it's smiling you're
like oh they're gonna trade Jamaal Adams
that's what he's getting that guy's
number for the Miami Dolphins have three
picks but here they get lucky I guess
you'd call it lucky and get a player
that I believe is the franchise
quarterback in Joe burrow from LSU can
we stop calling this man a one-year
wonder lie I love Peter King he's a
mentor of mine an idol of mine as a
sportswriter I even saw Heat he wrote it
like Jojo Burroughs one year wonder he's
not he's not a one year wonder let's
stop with that nonsense the Miami
Dolphins they need a leader they need a
tough quarterback someone who can move
around a little bit but can also throw
the ball down the field
I think burrow is the pick here I know
there's been talk about offensive line I
actually don't like this offensive line
class very much with Judy off the board
there's not a skill player I would take
over a quarterback so it's Joe burrow
for me yeah it's hard to disagree there
I mean there's gonna be a lot of Jets
fans and I'm not ready for this
conversation yet they're gonna wonder if
they need to think about taking a
quarterback I believe in Samms arnold's
I think he's been given a raw deal he's
22 years old we've seen flashes of
brilliance from him I mean he was the
AFC Player of the Week against the
Cowboys so I don't think the Boro
conversation starts for the Jets yet but
in this scenario for the Dolphins pretty
good for him to fall to them at four
that would be really interesting number
five we've been doing this pick for
weeks there's no reason to change it if
the Falcons are picking at five chase
young is gone they're not moving on from
Matt Ryan
Jerry Judy's gone
not taking a receiver anyway it's Jeff
Okuda get a number one shutdown corner
that Scott length he's got ball skills
he's fluid this is an easy pick for me
for Atlanta they're probably gonna have
a new coaching staff in there and I
think they need to prioritize the
secondary right here yeah that's a pick
that you're gonna see me make it's
either chase younger Jeff CUDA bass
exactly it's chase young if they stay
right around here it's Jeff Akutan
number six the New York Giants a lot of
people are gonna get on me and say left
tackle because Nate's older has not been
good or hey even right tackle because
they need help over there because Mike
Rimmer's has not been great either
I don't value any of the offensive
tackles this early and I know it could
happen guys float up the board based on
position of value she's not there for me
I think the Dave gentlemen and and again
we're talking about a guy who got
criticized a lot in Carolina for not
drafting offensive linemen early I think
he goes back to his roots he drafts a
linebacker
we heard alec ogle trees name mentioned
a lot in the trade market after the
deadline heated up isaiah simmons is
perfect for what they're doing
defensively whether they want to run a
30 front or a 40 front or play nickel or
play dime this guy never has to leave
the field and that's if you're gonna
draft an off ball linebacker
early dan better be a guy who never has
to leave the field
that's isaiah simmons started as a
safety moves down i play some linebacker
and he's just a hybrid but he's never
gonna leave the field and he's excellent
for what you want to do when you have to
get to five and six DBS but he's also i
mean he could blitz he could stop the
run I think Isaiah Simmons is one of the
best players in this class yeah that's
the kind of player the Giants need they
just need an absolute playmaker for
their defense that can handle a lot of
different roles and and just keep
stacking as they really rebuild that
unit alright number seven here the
Cleveland Browns this pick it's probably
the easiest one I'll have to make at
this is where Andrew Thomas goes get
yourself a tackle he listened he could
play really anywhere on the offensive
line and the Browns need help at a lot
of places on the offensive line but
Andrew Thomas would do wonders for their
run game with Nick Chubb which just
comes and goes nobody understands why
and would also help Baker Mayfield and
pass protection so I really like Andrew
Thomas in this spot number eight the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers I'm not gonna go
quarterback and the reason is because
I've now watched Bruce Arians defend
Jameis Winston too many times to think
that they won't give him more time
to try to acclimate in this system I
think we see Jamis probably do a
two-year deal where the Bucks can say
we've seen flashes we want a chance to
develop this guy so I think he comes
back and the Bucks would now be open to
draft someone like grant Delpit which is
where I have them going here I would not
be surprised by a Tristan Dwarfs type
pick the Bruce Arians says hey I also
need some help on that offensive line
but the defense needs an assist as well
I think Grant Albert's perfect for what
Todd Bowles does defensively look at
Jamal Adams what he used to be before
Greg Williams ruined him and that is
what great well will be for Todd Bowles
and yet you're not taking works here
benefits me because number nine the
Broncos they need offensive line help
tristan whoops is on the board play I'm
at left tackle blame at right tackle I
don't care you need to help Garrett
Bowles has not been any good this pick
makes way too much sense the Broncos are
in a situation where they need to truly
accept rate and I know they beat the
Browns and it's an exciting win but the
brown the Broncos need to accept a
reality that they're gonna have to do a
little bit of rebuild rebuild here in
the trenches and they're probably gonna
have a pick in the top ten which will
benefit that got to go offensive line
with wharfs yeah get drew lock some help
up front because they need it number ten
the Oakland Raiders this is from the
Chicago Bears never thought that would
happen
what it is is from Al Davis it is they
need speed on D on offense in the worst
way after losing the Antonio Brown we
saw them you know rumored of guys like
oh maybe Robbie Anderson maybe they get
someone like an Emmanuel Sanders they
need speed offensively this does it
Henry rugs is the fastest player in
college football if you saw Tyreke LLL
catch Damian Williams on Sunday that's
the kind of speed Henry rug's has I know
we don't always see it in college
because there's not like those huge open
field runs a lot with rugs wait until
the combine when he runs a legit four to
five or four to four al Davis is gonna
sit up in his grave and hunt mike Mayock
until he makes this pick henry rugs is
perfect for Oakland and that this is the
only thing their offense is missing by
the way in offenses been played very
very well as of late I think also Mayock
at GM he's gonna tap into those big
programs like we saw last year clemson
alabama rugs checks all the boxes for
Oakland yeah I love it there and I'm
gonna stick with wide receiver at number
11 for the Cardinals and go CD lamb
I think this would be the perfect guy
forklift Kingsbury's offense with Kyler
Murray I mean listen they know each
other already those to this there's
already the chemistry here between Kyler
and CD lamb and I think we've talked
about this in the past before Matt we
don't know how much they're gonna value
offensive line overall either way I
don't really know if there's one that I
want to take in this spot for that
offense and the kind of offensive
lineman that they need CD would be a
consistent ad catch guy in this offense
for well over a thousand yards every
year at a position that they need
consistency and a little more youth that
right now
yeah Larry Fitzgerald might be done so
that pick makes a lot of sense number 12
the Detroit Lions I haven't going Derek
Brown who is a top eight player on my
big board the defensive lineman from
Auburn not necessarily the biggest need
for Detroit but this screams Matt
patrícia to me this is a very bob coin
New England tine type of move excuse me
get a big guy in the middle who can not
only stop the run but he can generate a
ton of pressure up the middle like
Derrick Brown it's one of the biggest
sleepers in the country like I said top
eight player for me but he's just not
getting a lot of love nationally I think
that'll change as we start to see the
SEC schedule heat up in November
Derrick Brown is a monster and he would
be great for Detroit yeah their defense
I mean considering that's Matt Patricius
calling card it's struggling right now
you give up 31 points to the Raiders 26
to the Giants 42 to the Vikings I mean
they got to stop the bleeding here and
Derrick Brown is the kind of impact
player that can help with that number
thirteen the Jaguars talked about
earlier in the show a Gardner Minshew
haven't loved what I've seen from a lot
of this offense besides Gardner and
Leonard fournette I'm gonna go Trey
Smith here I know there's gonna be
health concerns and medical checks are
gonna be huge for him but you watch the
film and this guy has around one Talent
he played tackle as a freshman he's
dominating his guard this year and when
I talk about dominating there are some
Quentin Nelson moments on film for the
sky where he is putting people 6 feet
under in the dirt he's moving piles he's
nasty and he's doing it against teams
like Alabama that's what matters here so
I love Trey Smith and I think for
Jacksonville this fits the identity of
that offense
yeah trey is gonna be one of the most
interesting players if he declares to
evaluate because it so much is going to
be hinged on medicals
and where do you play them do you play
Matt left tackle where he was really
good as a freshman do you play a guard
where he's killing people right now on
the field the only thing I've heard
about him that maybe would be a negative
other medical is just conditioning but
he was yeah bayar
he is big I think he's much bigger than
the 325 he's listed at so that'll be
something to watch number 14 the Los
Angeles chargers Philip Rivers a free
agent guys and I know we don't like to
talk about it but he is also getting
older we've seen quarterbacks from that
draft class Eli Manning already be
replaced Ben Roethlisberger that by
injury maybe is open the door to Mason
Rudolph but one thing that we saw the
Giants and the Steelers do is draft
quarterbacks of the future they tried to
get guys in there to develop the
Chargers have not done that then now
it's time even if you bring Phil back
for a year or two they need someone to
develop its quarterback in future I'm
gonna give them Justin Harbor you keep
him on the west coast you match him up
with a head coach and Anthony Lin who
would be very very good I believe for
what Herbert can do offensively and he's
a good athlete he has a killer arm six
foot six 235 pounds the only knock on
him that you hear is decision-making
even though he hasn't thrown a lot of
picks this year I think that offense
really sets the table for him but then
you just hear that he's not this like
killer you know he doesn't have that the
instincts and the excuse me not the
instincts but he doesn't have just that
Moxie where guys you're like oh my god I
have to follow him you know that Baker
Mayfield or Phillip Rivers type
leadership but anyway Herbert the skills
are good enough to get him at the top 15
picks of this draft well speaking of a
quarterback prospect that's not entirely
too different number 15 here for the
Tennessee Titans I'm going with Jacob
Eason big arm big body definitely some
questions about decision making
definitely some questions I know you've
said in the past about overall maturity
if he's ready to be an NFL quarterback
leading the huddle but you see the
physical talent and the fastball that
this guy could fit into tight windows it
is truly special and I think for Mike
Vrabel
he's gonna be looking for a guy like
that that can basically make any throw
on the football field
Tennessee they've gotten the most out of
Ryan Tannehill after moving on from
Marcus Mariota I'm not ready to say he's
their quarterback of the future right
now right and even if they believed they
could go into next year with him as the
starter developing a guy like Eason at
this value
makes a ton of sense yeah with Eason my
only knock on him is he doesn't play
well against good teams like we haven't
seen him never get like Utah I mean sure
Cal a light through four touch does be
through two picks and didn't I just
don't think he plays that well against
against good teams and another guy who
we think he'll declare but he does have
another year of eligibility the Oakland
Raiders the last pick that they have in
the first round this is their original
pick I'm going back to a big program and
it's Kay LaVon chase on from LSU a guy
we're gonna get see against Alabama this
weekend this will be enormous for his
draft stock because he's been quiet at
times but he's turned it on in big games
like think about the Florida game he
really turned it on going against Alex
Leatherwood that is the matchup of the
weekend can he get by this Alabama
football Alabama front five excuse me
thank goodness who is just exceptional
this year they've done a great job of
protecting whether it's 200 or Mack
Jones I think what they haven't Jedrek
Willis what they have in Alex leather
what if chase on can get into the
backfield after those guys we're gonna
be talking about a player who's gonna be
the top 15 pick as long as everything
checks out medically for a dude that
missed all last season pick number 17
from the Miami Dolphins this pick is
actually from the minka Fitzpatrick
trade which is looking just fine after
that 96 yard interception touchdown
return this weekend but that's all fans
they're now second pick in the first
round I'm going with you tour gross my
toes now this is the first time in our
mock draft I've had him over AJ epinet
I just think the guy is a complete
football player for Penn State super
high character he can get after the
quarterback he could stop the run and
Chris Greer they're gonna be looking for
hits they went for a really really high
floor player and Christian Wilkins last
year I think gross tomatoes is gonna be
the same way and now you start to have a
Brian Flores rebuilt front seven with
this traffic yeah I like this a lot and
girls may know someone who has flown
under the radar a little bit because we
get so caught up talking about chase
young but he has been amazing in the Big
Ten as well number 18 the Philadelphia
Eagles who seemed content to finish
eighth and eight this year so they're
just like hovering around the middle of
the pack
probably gonna miss out on the speed at
receiver even though I think that's a
huge need for them so I'm gonna look at
the defense where I think they have at
times completely underperform
this year even though there's talent
back there I'm looking at the corner
position CJ Henderson would be a best
player available situation for me right
here but also I think comes at a
position of need so CJ Henderson a
physical cocky aggressive corner from
Florida I things to be a great fit for
what the Eagles do defensively it helps
get them back to where they're drafting
for future need they're drafting
physical fast guys on defense Henderson
would be a really good fit for them all
right moving on to the Carolina Panthers
here this is he my struggle to figure
out because last year during the mock
drafts we were constantly honored they
need to rebuild this offensive line
they've tried
they just haven't made very good
decisions to do it now I don't really
love anyone available in this spot nor
do I believe that they'll use another
premium asset on offensive line so I'm
going to go with the best value in this
spot and that is aja Panetta this gets
you two totally different edge rushers
you have a converting speed to straight
power kind of guy in epinet
Brian burns on the other side that's a
bendy twitchy explosive off the snap
kind of pass rusher I think that duo
would make a lot of sense for this
defensive line in Carolina they have to
continue to stack the offensive line but
I just don't think you could pass on
epinet at this spot of the draft yeah an
epinet interesting guy because it does
seem like his socket is falling back a
little fallible but I'll be interested
to see once we get to testing if it
jumps back up number 20 the Jacksonville
Jaguars this is from the Los Angeles
Rams I went to offensive line here I
don't think they're very happy with Cam
Robinson at left tackle they're gonna
have to make some hard decisions not
just a quarterback but when it comes to
free agency this year so I'm gonna go
with Alex Leatherwood we talked about
him a little bit
earlier in the show from Alabama a guy
who started out at right tackle which is
gonna remind you of people like camera
but saying to John Williams ended up a
left tackle but I really do like his
ability I think he's poised he's patient
he has recovery speed but what they have
to do if Yannick ikkaku is gone we might
see this become a pass rusher if Kelvin
Smith he's never coming back we can see
this be a linebacker there are a lot of
directions that the Jags could go but
right now I think offensive tackles the
biggest need so I'm gonna give them
Leatherwood yeah so they went offensive
line with both of our first-round picks
in this mock draft and they should be
excited about that new
rebuilt SEC look between Trey Smith
Alex Laird they got a tackle they got a
guard put up there to the left side and
just wrecked people Leonard fournette
can run for 1500 yards behind those guys
I really like that style of play 21 the
Dallas Cowboys they're gonna have an
interesting offseason when they look at
their cornerback group where they could
just draft on right here if the Jets are
not making this pick the I have the
Cowboys sagan christian fall in it's
crazy to say he's been the second-best
corner on his team because true freshman
Stingley has been maybe the best corner
in the country I don't know it's
ridiculous but don't sleep on Fulton and
guess what he could be going in the top
ten after this weekend he can go out of
the first round when we get to see him
against Jerry Judy and Henry rugs this
weekend out in Tuscaloosa I'm so excited
Derrick Stingley junior as well like oh
my god this desam I'm gonna head myself
we'll save it for the Friday show but
I'm very excited for that matchup
number 22 the Indianapolis Colts a team
again they could go a lot of different
directions here because we're seeing
Chris Ballard start to fill in the outer
edges of his team I'm gonna go with a
pass rusher who has been quiet early
this year but I feel like he's starting
to turn it on Terrell Lewis is someone I
was watching two years ago in thinking
this guy's gonna be a top-10 pick
eventually but then injuries happen but
now he's getting healthy you see him
making monster plays for Alabama and
just like we talked about with
Leatherwood and Fulton and other guys
chase on the trail Lewis has a big game
against LSU I think we're gonna see a
big game is Auburn we're gonna see a big
game and there's championship game
potentially Terrell Lewis
if healthy has all the traits to be
around one pass rusher and to be a very
special one
I think Ballard and the Colts are smart
enough to understand value from a guy
who maybe he's been banged up in the
past but as long as you get a clean bill
of health he looks perfect for what they
want to do it just in Houston's you know
old guy that's that's not a long-term
option there I think pass rusher is a
big big need for the Colts yeah I think
so too they've also dealt with some
injuries in that position group this
year where they really got to reevaluate
it but like you said just in Houston
still a good player but you know he's
gonna be 31 years old next year and they
need to add more talent up front
Minnesota Vikings they're shockingly
kind of getting run on recently I mean
you definitely saw it this week
with Damien Williams Matt I'm gonna give
them some defensive line help Siobhan
Kinlaw this is quietly one of the bigger
risers of the lair just for what he's
done for his stock we talked about it
with Jim naggy the last time he was on
the show Kinloss a beast up front and
absolute beasts and he's just getting
better and better yeah this would be a
senior pic for the Vikings rather than
taking on it I still like the ceiling
though is there fork in law even though
that he is in his senior year so they
need help up front it's as simple as
that it's weird to say that about
Minnesota because it feels like they
rarely do but right now this is a
position they probably should address I
love Javon Kinlaw he is he's just every
week he moves up my board more and more
every time I get a chance to watch him
play number 20 for the Kansas City
Chiefs hey don't yell at us about the
order this is just where teams are
ranked right now okay like I get it
the Chiefs could still be the number two
seed in the AFC but lay off us this is
this is based on the current standings
okay I'm going offensive line here and I
know that might be popular in some
sections of Kansas City and wildly
unpopular in others there'd be people
saying why didn't you take Kenneth
Murray or why didn't you take a corner
well I like Kenneth Murray a lot but I
think we've seen like Anthony Hitchens
and Reggie Ragland like that crew
they're getting it done lately
especially not the defensive line is
healthy the offensive line on the other
hand has been absolutely terrible even
when Eric Fisher comes back even when
Laverne Tate tardy from back do you need
help in the middle we've seen that at
left guard we've seen it at center I'm
going to a Tyler be a dish from
Wisconsin he has been phenomenal this
year even as the Badgers have struggled
at times watch those inside runs from
Jonathan Taylor you're you're going to
see him consistently winning at the
first and second level I ain't gonna
play guard he could play Center I would
plug him in a Center for Kansas City and
never think about that position at least
for the next five years let my homes
have that stability of I know who's in
front of me and I trust him they don't
have that right now at center for Kansas
City yeah it's crazy they really do need
to kind of re-evaluate that group
because you look at some of the hits
mahomes was taking when he was on the
field you got to protect that guy
absolutely all cost I was sticking with
interior offensive line here this is for
the Dolphins now the third time they're
picking in this first round creed
Humphrey now Miami
they simply outplayed the Jets
their offense destroyed Gregg Williams
defense but if you look at the offensive
line they're still starting some backup
level players they're where they're
gonna look to rebuild this unit
especially because they're gonna have a
young quarterback back there very soon
that they need to protect
I think Creed Humphrey is a guy that
will fit the Brian Flores identity of
the bill where hey we want to punch you
in the face we want to run the football
I'd really like what I've seen from him
on film this year and I think he has a
legitimate chance to sneak into the back
end around one the fact that they lost
four starters on that offensive line and
Craig Humphrey was the only do they came
back and they really haven't seen a drop
off a play their shows a lot of things
about that it's really really impressive
number 26 the Buffalo Bills they're
gonna draft a receiver in the first
round guys it's just barring a major
free agency acquisition or trade this
offseason they will be drafting receiver
in the first round t Higgins is the best
one available for me here still six foot
four 200 pounds he has the frame I think
we've talked about before with Josh
Allen not the most accurate quarterback
I would like to give him a pass catcher
who has a big catch radius for me that's
t Higgins here I almost went Michael
Pittman junior from USC that's how much
I love his game but I think Higgins is
still the better overall prospect right
now yeah he fits what Josh Allen needs
really go up and win the football like
you said you know have that big catch
radius the Green Bay Packers man what a
wake-up call that great team they've had
a great start they simply got outplayed
in every at you know every aspect of the
game against the Chargers over this
weekend I'm gonna go Trey Adams here I
think he's a really really good
offensive tackle he can run block he
could pass block I think you know the
bigger question with him was how is he
gonna rebound from these surgeries and
from these injuries and he just looks
great Green Bay has to get younger on
the offensive line and I think Troy
Adams fits the bill in this spot of the
draft ya bribable uggs free agent I mean
that's something you gotta be ignored is
that they have to start thinking about
getting younger and rebuilding this team
with Rogers contract there's some guys
on defense they paid last year they're
gonna have to start being creative
number 28 the Seattle Seahawks it's a
really a hard team to pick for at this
point because we'll Jadeveon Clowney be
back and for me like that's a huge issue
if clowny is gonna be back okay well
then you can go other areas if he's not
then I think you have to start thinking
long term Dwayne
Brown has been amazing for Seattle since
they acquired him via trait
he's also 34 years old he'd be 35 when
the season starts next year and you have
to start thinking ahead about this
offensive line how well they're playing
now with a good unit upfront you want to
try to keep that going so I'm gonna give
them Austin Jackson from USC struggled a
little bit against Oregon on Saturday
night but I still love the athleticism
here he's one of the few left tackles in
this class when you look at his body
you're like yep that's the left tackle
you know he has that long athletic lean
but muscular build and you see it in his
movement he's got to probably get a
little bit stronger on the inside
shoulder but I like Austin Jackson and
for Seattle this is not an immediate
need but this is a future need almost
went Trayvon Diggs here because he's I
mean if you've ever seen him at corner
he he's like a DK Metcalf type corner
he's just against God
ya X foot to 200 pounds no fat so I
could see them going that direction here
but Austin Jackson makes the most sense
well speaking of Greek god I don't know
if you've seen how Kenneth Murray looks
this year compared to last year man yeah
I mean another guy just with an insane
build I'm putting him on the Baltimore
Ravens here at 29 listen when you look
at Murray he could really do it all
sideline to sideline speed good pursuit
good IQ the position value of linebacker
gets lost a lot where he could end up
being a top 25 player in this draft and
it doesn't mean he'll go in the top 25
but I think you look at Baltimore God
the offensive line is so good it's
almost becoming a team that it's
actually kind of hard to find some needs
for them as crazy it is to say and there
wasn't really a corner I wanted for them
at this spot of the draft so with
Baltimore there they could honestly be
one of those teams where it becomes hard
to draft for them just keep stacking the
deck in the front seven they lost CJ
mostly to free agency
maybe Kenneth Murray could be that next
great Ravens linebacker I was going to
take Kenneth Murray here at number 30
overall but you stolen from me
consolation prize New Orleans Saints
okay we'll take Dylan Moses who again
probably would have been a top 10 or 12
prospect for me before getting hurt this
year everything I've heard he's on track
to be just fine but by the time maybe
even about time to combine comes around
he might be ready to do some drills
Moses is just a prototypical Mike
Leinbach
who never has to leave the field like
we're talking about with Isaiah Simmons
as I would say about Kenneth Murray this
is a modern linebacker class with these
three guys where they're able to play
neckl their male played I'm there your
three down linebacker like a Tremayne
Edmonds and Buffalo I think Dylan Moses
is a really special player only question
mark could be injury right now yeah it's
crazy I mean it's just hard to get a lot
of conversation going around him because
he's he's out for the year but when it
comes back to the draft everyone's gonna
look at him maybe they'll go back and
watch the tape from 2018 which we did
over the summer and go damn you know
what we'll take a guy like that we feel
like he's fully recovered all right
here's my typical you haven't heard this
name in the first round of any mock
drafts yet but you're getting it right
here New England has gotten nothing from
the tight end position this year and
that offense needs to going forward
hunter Bryant from Washington good
production right now he's a great
athlete he really reminds me of Evan
Engram Matt that's how he was Bill he's
just six-foot to 240 pounds he runs like
a wide receiver he's great after the
catch you can move him around and do a
lot of different things with him I think
this guy would be a star in the Patriots
offense yeah not the biggest guy you
know so they're y'all back Thomas More's
back type build yeah move tight in where
you can get him all over the field this
is what they've been missing in New
England for sure
now number 32 and it feels so good to
put them here the San Francisco 49ers
they're in a position where depending on
what happens in free agency again I know
we're saying that a lot but you know
guys like D Ford who's been a bit player
he could be free after this year Arik
Armstead is a free agent Jimmy Ward is
having a breakout year he's a free agent
so things could really hinge on what
happens there but as of right now I
would look at this corner class Richard
Sherman's getting older a killer
Weatherspoon has been banged up a little
bit like I said Jimmy Ward's a free
agent I would be all over a local guy
Paulson a Deebo right down the road at
Stanford who we're gonna see in a couple
weeks when we're doing the tailgate tour
out there I believe that he could be a
top 20 player in this class he has sized
it led them the NC double-a I believe
last year passed his defense so you know
we asked ball skills I'm a huge believer
in a Deebo he's just been a little bit
quiet because he isn't underclassmen and
I think he's a dude who because it's
pac-12 and because Stanford's not good
this year he's not gonna play but six
one one
he fits that mold of what the Niners
want at the corner position all right
that's our mock draft tweet us let us
know what you think a stick to football
follow us don't forget false on
instagram a stick to football and check
out the the YouTube page we'll take a
break we'll come back and finish this
thing off with your draft on draft
questions
it is draft on draft time and if it
wasn't ten 18 in the morning we would
crack Spears but we do plenty last
weekend in Alabama where you should be
to buy 1018 a.m. Saturday morning we
will be feeling it it would be a good it
would be a good morning
I think our foods due to arrive around
this time so it'd be good that was my
next question
when we get intermission I need to check
I need to check and see what time I had
food I think the earliest possible was
five hours before kickoff so that would
be 10:30 and I mean 9:30 worried an
early West oh that's awesome
yeah we have a gasket we have pulled
pork we have a nacho bar we have okay I
just went like what I was pretty hungry
when I did it I was like oh that sounds
good oh that sounds good so it yeah
it'll be a good time free food free
drinks and a lot of free hugs all right
damn super first question and I want you
to answer this one first
can Sam darn 'old be saved well he can
but Adam GaSe it needs to be on the
highway but by the time everyone's
listened to this show I mean okay here's
the positives with Sam's Arnold he's 22
years old we've seen games where he's
been phenomenal not just the Dallas game
this year but you go back to last year
how he played against Houston how he
played against Green Bay he looked like
a quarterback that had top-five ability
but the games that he's bottoms out
which have been a lot of them recently
he doesn't let a play die the mechanics
are falling apart and there's simply
just reckless decisions now the issue
you have to have with it are a couple
things and Joe Douglas is gonna take
care of this first one they need a new
offensive line this isn't where you're
going to the auto shop and you're
getting an oil change and they go oh you
know yeah you need to change the brake
pads this is where you take the car and
you
give it to the dealership for whatever
piece-of-shit amount of money they give
you back because you need a whole new
car they need to go into free agency
they need to explore the trade market
when they call teams and offer Jamal
Adams and whoever else it may be and
they need to go into the draft as a
let's add to this not let's build this a
lot of people are going into the draft
and going oline rounds one two three and
whatever on the jet I love that it's not
gonna work that way it's not gonna work
that way
you really need to be creative you're
gonna have money to spend you need to
invest in the offensive line and the
bottom line is Matt they need just
honestly better plays calls when it Sam
has made bad decisions and is
responsible for some of this but they
don't get him on the move
they have precise standing on top of
each other they don't utilize levy on
bail it's just unbelievable how inept
things have been from top to bottom but
in terms of the talent this guy has and
I know you really agree with that point
yeah it's not this isn't doomed it just
needs a lot of changes I dress my son up
as a Ghostbuster for Halloween I tried I
tried nothing Sami people didn't think
that was funny here's what's crazy you
go back to yesterday and after he threw
the second touchdown to Ryan Griffin
that was overturned for no reason
yeah no reason he would had a super high
completion percentage two touchdowns no
turnovers but once that confidence goes
from a stupid turnover everything just
goes all the way downhill and I don't
think it's just Sam's confidence I think
it's the offensive lines confidence sure
confidence in the play call and you know
he makes the horrible decision to throw
that ball up in the end zone Oh terribly
if a Jets player catches that it leads
everything for the weekend it goes viral
on Twitter and it goes viral on
Instagram and it like everything it's
like oh my God look at this play instead
it's oh dude what are you doing and it
and then it's the not picking the ball
up in the endzone for the safety it's
just it just feels like there's a
disconnect on this team and there's I
don't think there's a lot of discipline
I don't think there's a lot of belief
and what they're doing a lot of
confidence so Sam I'm not worried about
Sam like I am about some of the other
young quarterbacks like a Mitchell true
Biscay even like with what we're seeing
with Baker like Baker has time in
he's not processing what he's seeing I
think with Arnold I mean yeah like it
seems like he's quickening up his
delivery his footwork is not where it
needs to be a lot of that to me says I
don't trust my offensive line so that I
still have hope for Sam Darla like you
said he's what 22 years old hey he's got
a lot of a lot of time to fix what's
going on just needs some help next
question from our guy fares Murata when
a certain team drafts a certain position
just your image of that player change
like when the Steelers draft a receiver
yes not that your image of that player
changes but you're like oh [ __ ] like
last year with a Chiefs drafted me Cole
Hardman we looked at each other and
we're like of course of course they did
you know like this is the perfect fit
for him and I think you even see that
sometimes like you know with
quarterbacks you see a guy goes to when
you're like that's a great spot mahomes
going to Kansas City oh my god this is a
great spot or you see bad fits at times
too so it can go both ways where you get
really excited about a player we used to
have like I don't think it ever made it
on camera but we used to joke like
you're doing the draft whoever the
Browns took is like God
they just he's gonna bust like they just
ruined this guy's career hopefully that
has changed but I think it definitely
affects because environment and
situation are huge for a player success
so you would be foolish not to factor
that in yeah it really does we go
through it all the time and I think
running back is a big one there's guys
that just fit in certain systems where
you know the guy's gonna run for a
thousand yards speedy receivers is a big
one vertical threats and I mean the list
goes on and on and on it really does so
yeah that's to answer the question quite
simply that a hundred percent factors
into things where you look at each other
you go well if he was ever gonna succeed
this is the only place where it would
probably happen yep
so yeah that's something that we've
talked a lot about it would be amazing
if we had time after the draft to say
these are our favorite fits like these
are the guys who's basically you would
have ranked them higher if you'd known
they could have gone to this team so
maybe maybe we'll actually get that done
this year all right I love this username
Coco's accent where would you rank John
Harbaugh among the best coaches in the
NFL so I think it we could be prisoners
of the moment right now and say oh my
god he's the top three or four coach but
I went on a rant earlier
the show we need to look at the forest
not just the trees I think John's a
really really good head coach and you
could look at the Super Bowl wind
you could look at what he's done for the
the length of his time there he's a
really good head coach I don't I mean
he's not up there with Belichick for me
obviously he's not up there with Andy
Reid for me I still think you can look
at guys like Pete Carroll I would put
Pete above him I think as far as like
the young coach just go I'm not being a
Homer here I think Kyle Shanahan's one
of the best coaches in the NFL I think
John is firmly in that tier two though
of this guy's just a really good head
coach he's a good CEO he's a good leader
he's a good innovator he does a great
job of think about what the Ravens look
like two years ago and think of what
they look like right now they completely
flipped this team's image and he hasn't
like a Pete Carroll in this way the
message hasn't gotten stale he went from
a veteran team with a stale last
quarterback and a great defense to now a
young team with an exciting quarterback
and they're playing two completely
different brands of football I think
that's what John's really shown that
he's great at is being able to adapt and
innovate and still get his message
across to a different team yeah I think
he's a top-five coach in the NFL I mean
right now when you look at it for me it
would start with Bill so the top five is
some kind of order of Bill Belichick
Kyle Shanahan Sean Payton Sean McVeigh
and Harbaugh I think that would be the
five firm you wouldn't put meat Carroll
or Andy Reid up there
oh man that way that's like that's where
I think John's probably set in the top
seven or yeah but that order could be
maybe I put him over Pete I'll say that
and this is why I think Russell Wilson
is easily one of the best quarterbacks
the most underrated quarterbacks in the
league for a while now where I mean I
thought Flacco besides the
flash-in-the-pan Super Bowl championship
was never really good yeah you know
that's the thing for me with Harbaugh
that he's he always gets the most out of
guys and Pete's a good coach Pete's a
good coach sometimes I wonder what Pete
would be without Russ and you could say
that for so many guys Andy I take it
back Andy has to be in the top five
because Andy could do it with almost
anyone right that's what makes it so
special
it's tricky it's tough Harbaugh is a
great coach so I mean he's 60s right now
he's 10 and 6
the playoffs he almost has a 600 winning
percentage are they 12 and 3 under it
with Lamar I think I want to say that
numbers right yes I mean he's been
really really good
John has and it's great I tell you this
all the time he was one loss away from
being the head coach of the New York
Jets yeah
the Jets were all in on going after him
all in it would be a completely
different world right now
yeah one that I would like to live in
right like oh man all right I'm gonna
read this one because I'm kind of very
excited for Matt's reaction and I'm not
even gonna answer I'm just gonna let
Matt take it away Wilhelm von stupid is
there a more worthless offseason edition
than Frank Clark what's the worst
offseason edition that came with
publicity this season our all time
besides Albert Haynesworth
I don't think he got that much Pub did
it maybe it I live in like the Kansas
City media bubble sometimes so it's like
you got talked about a lot here I
thought he'd be really good yeah I did
too and I thought he was a top 5 pass
rusher heading into the year he's hurt I
think that like that's the s key he is
hurt it's a neck injury and that's like
not something I'm gonna piss on it's not
like he hurt his thumb and he's not
playing the dude has a neck injury so it
that seems pretty serious to me and a
good reason for him to not be out there
now in the 7 games he played before that
he had three sacks and he had two in the
Denver game right before he got hurt so
I think with Frank Clark and I've said
this a lot to people down here in the
Kansas City area we've seen now eight
games and Frank Clark was brought in to
win the next 11 games he was brought in
to get you a number one or number two
seed and then to make a run to and
through New England to the Super Bowl
that's why you saw it traded for Frank
Clark and gave him the money
I still think and I know he's not gonna
probably end up with a double-digit
sacks season this is about long-term
what the Chiefs want to be upfront with
Frank Clark and Chris Jones and then
some you can have bit pieces beside
those guys and Derek naughty looks good
Colin Saunders looks good Alex Aquifer
actually leads the team in sacks with
four and a half as a low budget player
having Frank and Chris let's you fill in
those gaps with draft picks and cheap
guys who can be role players so I still
think the construction of this team is
really really smart and the Chiefs right
now I mean they're five and three and
after watching New England on Sunday
night after watching Baltimore on Sunday
night who knows what the next eight
weeks is gonna do to the AFC but getting
this Chiefs team healthy then I think we
can look at Frank Clark and say okay it
was worth it if he sacks Lamar Jackson
or Tom Brady and the AFC Championship
game and gets the Chiefs to a Super Bowl
no one's gonna care that he got hurt for
a couple weeks in the middle of the
season it's not gonna matter at all
again
we're living to week to week when it
comes to the NFL and I think your point
about him being such a key addition to
the run defense is what it really came
down to where this is why they went for
him instead of keeping D Ford they want
a player that could shut down the run
because by the way D Ford is playing
like 30 percent of the snap I mean
that's what he is they don't need him
but I that kills me when Chiefs fans are
like oh we should have kept D Ford no no
you shouldn't have because you need
someone who can play 75 80 percent of
the snaps D Ford's knee does not allow
him to do that
man you guys need darker [ __ ] to worry
about over that's about B I wish all
right like all my best friends other
than you were cheap Spain so I like live
in their world and I've seen the highs
and lows this year we got a fire feat
she doesn't know what he's doing and now
they're like oh my god we can still be
the number two seed maybe the number one
seed it's like they are on a roller
coaster week to week because like this
they've never had Super Bowl aspirations
and most of their lives and they don't
know what to do with it so when they
lose the sky is falling [ __ ] it let's
burn it down for next year and when they
win it's like we're the best team ever
so they're learning they're like a
little baby football fan that's learning
how to do it alright our last question
of the show from Garrett Greenlee this
topic has never talked about but in the
seventh round two teams tend to take
players that are geographically located
close to them and kind of hope they work
out or do they still have a strategy at
that late in the draft and when seldom
picks work out so I'll say this is a
good question
it's very not a boilerplate quote we
can't just say everyone does it this way
a reason that you'll see a team
like the Denver Broncos get a Philip
Lindsay who is in their backyard he's
because the sixth and especially the
seventh round is being run more by your
scallops like your area Scouts are gonna
come in a lot in the seventh round and
say okay we like this guy they're gonna
be in there trying to call you DFAS to
get those deals done so they're gonna be
very involved in the process in the
seventh round that's why you might see
more geographical guys is because the
area Scouts are getting involved it also
could be because the GM has seen those
guys in person because they're right
there in the back yard so he's been able
to make it out to those games so it does
happen but teams that do well late in
the draft and do well with their
undrafted free agent signings that's not
the general manager that's the scout so
guys ask us a lot how can you know such
and such as a good Scout you can look at
the players late in the draft or
undrafted that their team has got you
know at if you're a Niners fan there's
you know SEC Scout might be the guy or
if you're a Jets fan it might be you
know pac-12 Scout what they're doing
late in the draft so that's I think the
7th round more credit should be given to
those area Scouts director or college
scout for the job that they're doing so
it can be geographical just because the
strength of that area scout but but it's
not so much of like well you know okay
we are we're the Chiefs let's get a guy
from Mizzou because that'll you know
we'll have some fans buy some extra
tickets you don't need help selling
tickets in Kansas City you need help
getting to the quarterback so I don't
think it's always about there isn't like
a conspiracy theory to get local guys in
that way yeah I think local guys come
more often with tryouts and sometimes
you DFAS you definitely nail it with the
scouts the area Scouts signed the you
DFAS those are guys that have their
relationships with the player those are
the guys trying to convince them to come
to the team and the opportunity they'll
have the seventh round it's interesting
it can go a couple different ways you do
see sometimes you know teams take Flyers
on closer guys that they felt were
priority players but a lot of the times
that really does go more to the tryout
camp and by kind of players so oh man
that was a good show in a long show good
show long show we'll be back tomorrow
Connor and I doing we're fixing the
Browns so happy Browns fixing day we
made it to November 5th this year
congratulations also I think we're gonna
have to talk a lot about college because
it sounds like Greg Schiano is going to
Rutgers Florida State
Lane
Kiffin has put out to people that he
would be interested in that job so he
might be talking it might be a college
football heavy day but we will be fixing
the Browns and we will be taking your
draft on draft questions so send those
in and if you haven't already subscribe
at iTunes or Apple podcast now stitch
your Spotify wherever you get your shows
and go to youtube bleach reports page
and subscribe to this playlist will talk
to you all Wednesday morning